britney spears wins big in court she  wins the right to hire her own attorney  who can advocate for her own rights  in the most recent conservatorship  hearing the judge accepted the  resignation of her former counsel and  accepted the appointment  of her new lawyer matthew rosengart who  comes from a very prestigious very large  law firm greenberg troy now rosengart is  a former federal prosecutor he seems to  have lots of experience and i'm sure  will represent britney spears very very  well  but it's odd that he doesn't appear to  have much conservatorship experience you  would think that in  a high profile conservatorship like the  one that britney spears is in that she  would hire someone who specializes in  conservatorships to make sure that she's  able to get out of this conservatorship  so we will see what happens next and we  will see all of them  in court